more than 20 trucks have been set to
light in three provinces in South Africa
nearly half of them in the province of
mpumalanga
here A man is caught on a dash cam
throwing fuel in a truck before setting
at a light and jumping out
trucks are often used to block roads
authorities have not established who's
behind the attacks and whether they're
connected but with high unemployment the
hiring of foreign truckers is fueling
tensions the first motive was the the
foreign drivers that's when they first
started out and closing towns and taking
keys of drugs that was because of
foreign drivers because they say I have
to employ African drivers but now it
looks to be like the extorting the
companies because they say okay listen
last week we burned 20 trucks now I'm at
your premises I say okay employ my 10
drivers you have to employ them for the
salary and with this conditions
those arrested are suspected to be
affiliated with the all truck drivers
Foundation or atdf we've said they want
more South Africans hired but they've
denied any involvement the government's
calling the arson economic sabotage two
years ago South Africa's economy lost
billions of dollars following riots
linked to the jailing of former
president Jacob Zuma
and it's worried these attacks May
further Stoke tensions in a country with
a third of the population out of work
Mary Pardi who heads a truck Owners
Association of South Africa says they're
already losing Revenue but now because
of you know this escalating violence and
the escalating issues that cannot be
resolved obviously they are pointing
back to the government it affects
operators and the economy is not growing
but in the actual fact is that we will
have to you know balance the scale and
make sure that we hire South African
truck drivers
the association says five years ago
foreigners made up 90 of truck drivers
it's since dropped marginally to between
70 and 80 percent 80 of goods
transported through
the suffer and their jobs and even their
lives could be lost in what's becoming
an increasingly dangerous industry